well in the long run democracy has to be
the answer I mean you know as I may be
wrong but everything I've been taught in
the ivory tower or everything I've
learned from reading about the rest of
the world will tell you that
authoritarianism ultimately it's not
tenable it's a band-aid strategy it
would work for two years five years ten
years but end of the day it's
inconceivable that the Middle East can
continue to grow in terms of demography
then continue to open up to the world
and learn the things about Internet
technology modern society etc and yet
and the gulf between aspirations of the
people and the government that they have
becomes wider and wider and nothing will
happen I mean logic will dictate you
that ultimately authoritarianism will
not last and we do see breakdowns look
at pakistan in the past year or so we
thought that the story in pakistan is
about moderation versus extremism this
is what we try to market and the
Pakistani said wait a minute that is not
the story your story is about freedom
and rule of law so we have the bizarre
episode you know pictures on New York
Times of policemen with long beards
beating up on lawyers in suits as the
opposite of what we assumed would be who
should be beating whom but the reality
of it is that we will see more Pakistan
happening we cannot gauge it we have to
realize that in the short run
authoritarian regimes may serve short
runs security stability interests of the
United States but in the long run at
some point in time authoritarianism will
no longer be the solution as we saw in
Pakistan will become itself the problem
the dilemma for US foreign policy is
that or what we know is right morally
and what we know what should happen in
the long run is one thing and our short
run needs are different
and our short run needs does not serve
things that we know ought to be true in
the long run and we have never been able
to bridge this gap in fact the Bush
administration is probably the first one
which at least at the level of rhetoric
try to create a bridge between what is
good for the Middle East in the long run
and say well you know that's good also
for the United States in the short run
but it bungled the whole thing so
abysmally that we're back to the old old
way of thinking with a vengeance nobody
everybody says yes in the long run we
shall all live in the Nirvana of
democracy but in the short run our
friends are the dictator